And just as before, it's the middle one.
There's a really large margin to the blue data set, but
a small margin to the x over here.
So it doesn't really maximize the margin to both data sets, just that's the one.
And the same is true for the line on the right side.
So the reason why we pick the one in between is
it seems to be most robust to classification errors.
If you pick a line that's really close to existing data, then a small amount of
noise would make the label over here flip and it feels not very robust.
So the inside of support vector machine
is to maximize robustness of your result.
And that makes them really great, so let's practice this.